[Música]
analizamos el caso de la joven estrella
rusa del patinaje artístico camila
valjevo quien sigue en competencia en
los juegos olímpicos de invierno pese a
haberse confirmado su dopaje en
diciembre de 2021 el tribunal de
arbitraje del deporte concluyó que
valiera de 15 años y favorita para el
oro en la competición individual no
tiene que ser suspendida de forma
provisional antes de una investigación
plena el tribunal falló a su favor
alegando que es menor por lo tanto una
persona protegida además el comité
consideró que impedir que la deportista
compitiera le causaría un daño
irreparable recordemos que validaba dio
positivo para three metas y dina un
fármaco prohibido para estos atletas la
agencia mundial antidopaje se unió a las
voces que mostraron su decepción por el
fallo del tas y subrayó que su código
mundial antidopaje no permite hacer
excepciones para ello entonces quiero
saludar al doctor mariano díaz médico
pediatra especialista en toxicología
miembro de la sociedad argentina de
pediatría y asociación toxicológica en
argentina gracias doctor por estar con
nosotros
américa de france 24 según estas normas
de la agencia mundial antidopaje la ama
aunque ella es una menor de edad no se
pueden hacer excepciones y debería ser
suspendida porque entonces han decidido
no hacer lo que está pasando realmente
con este caso de camila
buenos días gracias primero por la
invitación la sustancia de la tri metas
y dina de que tanto se está hablando
nosotros conocemos los pie atrás
especialista en toxicología con una
sustancia anti anginas a es decir para
prevenir o en el tratamiento de lo que
llamamos el síndrome coronario
crónico y lo que hace es mejorar el
flujo sanguíneo dándole mayor
rendimiento físico y mayor resistencia y
mejora el metabolismo y esto por un lado
está prohibido dentro de lo que llamamos
moduladores hormonales y metabólicos
está prohibido en la agencia mundial de
antidopaje y menos que se trata de una
de una menor es un fármaco que no está
permitido no cierto no está probado para
niños y niñas
tiene una estructura bastante compleja
este tipo de medicación la tri metas y
dina porque tiene dentro de su
composición lo que llama el anillo y
peras y mikonos que puede dar algún tipo
de trastorno a niveles del tipo
enfermedad de parkinson jana no es algo
inocuo como decimos nosotros pero en
definitiva estamos en una problemática
bastante muy muy muy muy compleja no
porque estamos hablando de una menor es
una línea no que es lo que a nosotros
prima como pediatra es la prioridad una
una niña es vulnerable no donde no es
ella la que hay que condenar sino hay
que tratarlo investigar a él en el
contexto no cierto el grupo del equipo
que la contiene que son los los
responsables de esta situación no
dejemos de considerar que es una línea y
eso es prioritario antes de pensar que
es una deportista si bien estamos en un
país donde las características o la
exigencias
se destacan en el deporte es muy
importante y hay que no hay que perder
de vista este tema de que se trata de
una menor y creo que las investigaciones
deben continuar para para ver cuál es la
intencionalidad como decimos los
toxicólogos no sean una intencionalidad
o como fue tomada la muestra de que hay
reacción cruzada con otro fármaco si se
respecto a la cadena de custodia como
siempre decimos la cadena de custodia es
desde que se tomó la muestra hasta el
momento qué tipo de exámenes o qué tipo
de metodología específica y sensible se
tomó no es cierto hay muchas cosas que
hay que investigar y sobre todo hay que
proteger a la menor porque no sabemos en
este en este ámbito muchas veces hay
situaciones de exigencia de los adultos
no en situaciones que bien sabemos de
violencia o de abuso de todo esto
entonces me parece que esto lo más
importante que hay que considerar para
no darles dos provocando un daño que
realmente sí creo que puede afectar a la
menor considerando si el deporte es una
actividad
fantástica no para el desarrollo 5
madurativo ahora autor como se considera
un fármaco prohibido en los deportes
como decir esta sustancia usted no se le
puede tomar porque cuando se le haga el
control de orina va a salir positivo en
el dopaje varía digamos en cada deporte
dr
claro está hay que considerarlo está
nombrado dentro de lo que es la agencia
mundial antidopaje del 2021 y que está
prohibido para los atletas y no tienen
que no tiene que estar este tipo de
fármacos
desconozco cuál es la sensibilidad
método utilizado no es por eso eso va a
variar muchísimo a la muerte y cómo fue
tomada porque ustedes saben que también
este tipo de medicación es tomada para
cuestiones de vértigo o patología de la
retina corio retiniana y entonces estas
son situaciones que uno tiene que
considerar y ver si hay alguna
estructura química que pueda asemejar la
tri metas irina y esto es fundamental
investigarlo porque de hecho está
prohibido pero hay que ser muy muy
cauteloso porque si uno habla de lo que
es mejorar el flujo sanguíneo también
hay situaciones como ciertos fármacos
como la aspirina que también es
utilizado para las cuestiones de
coagulación anticoagulante y un montón
de cuestiones de hemorragia entonces hay
que ser cauteloso y hay que ver a caso
particular no es cierto no se puede uno
ver dice que la anterior caso fue es
cada caso en particular y hay que
estudiarlo hasta hasta el final no es
cierto no condenaran
digamos que entonces el tas tendría la
razón en ese en ese sentido de dejarla
competir hasta que se haga una
investigación exhaustiva como usted lo
dije como usted lo dijo en contrario a
la agencia mundial antidopaje que dice
que si efectivamente no se pueden hacer
excepciones igual teniendo en cuenta que
es una menor de edad que pues le puede
afectar en su carrera pero que pues dio
posición para dopaje y no se pueden
hacer excepciones entonces está ahí esa
contradicción entre sentadas en la
agencia mundial antidopaje digamos quien
tiene más peso entre esas instituciones
que debería decidirlo
eso es eso no lo puedo terminarlo yo
coincido que hay un tribunal que hay que
respetar también y arbitra este tipo de
situaciones
antes de tomar una decisión que puede
causar determinar cosas determinados
daños a la menor no yo creo que sí es
una medida precautoria la que tomó el
tribunal de arriba no desde
para este tipo de situaciones y sin
perder tampoco lo que es hay que tener
en cuenta lo que la agencia mundial
también antidopaje tiene escrito no la
legalidad pero me parece que ya de
inicio condenar a la menor por ser una
situación vulnera así nosotros la
consideramos como una persona pero te
claro entonces me parece que hay que
protegerla ante todo amplia trias esto
es a nivel mundial el paciente
pediátrico hay que protegerlo porque
somos los adultos lo que muchas veces
exigimos obtenemos determinadas o si
coincido que hay que investigar hasta el
final doctor muy rápidamente 30 segundos
lo que pasa es que llama la atención
también de este caso que precisamente es
una atleta rusa y vive y vemos no en el
background de todos los atletas rusos
que han dado positivo por dopaje
entonces pues también sería algo pues
que digamos que está dentro de la
organización de atletas rusos
claro
digamos son países que se destacan como
rusia como japón todos los países
orientales se destacan estas disciplinas
y realmente si tienen algún tipo de
antecedente este tipo de modalidad de
exigencias de los entrenamientos pero
volvemos a lo mismo no hay que perder un
poquito de vista estos logros porque yo
veía en la decía en los medios riesgo al
oro oa la participación yo voy a la
paciente a la chica camina
individualmente es ella como selecciona
a ver si este tipo debe buscarse algún
tipo de situación de riesgo de maltrato
me parece que hay que utilizar eso
independientemente que represente a un
país que me parece fantástico esto desde
el cuádruple salto que ha tenido camisea
no pero realmente creo que hay que darle
una oportunidad y no ser por delante en
investigar al al entorno eso es una
esperemos entonces estaremos entonces
doctor esa investigación exhaustiva para
saber realmente qué fue lo que pasó en
este caso
y la polémica en todos los sentidos
doctor gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa un abrazo gracias a
ustedes por la invitación